where'd you get that dress I was buried
in it
well I never thought I'd say this but I
think I know what's going on in your
head oh well then welcome to the Terra
Dome I cannot be stopped
stop now
I don't care about that prize but I'm
gonna win because I want his happiness
to go away
oh my God you got blood all over me
thank you April luggate is beautiful
stop you're talented no but most
importantly you're passionate about
animals that's true it's because I'm
half wolf okay Donna you took a look I
have to tell you a secret but if you
tell anyone I will kill you slowly with
a giant syringe I really only listen to
like German Death Reggae and Halloween
sound effects records from the 1950s and
Bette Midler obviously
that's what I love about her
and that's why she deserves this award
sincerely Satan
fake blood capsules oh they didn't have
any really
that's gross I love it we are throwing a
Halloween party at our house it's gonna
be the greatest thing ever someone will
die of fun end of murder there's gonna
be beer pumpkins bloody goblins fake
ones it's gonna be awesome we have
decorations dead people that we just
murdered not murdered but pictures of
dead people from TV or movies mutilated
bodies favorite fake ones Candy dancing
tequila all kinds of food and snacks
blood orphans no blood orphans
I
I don't know what that is why should we
invest in the National Park Service
April well it is simple Leslie in
today's fast-paced society national
parks are still the best place for a
full moon werewolf transformation I'm an
eyebrow girl
I want to make out with them and chew
his eyebrows are
she's the cold
distant mother
I never had
I love her please I beg of you I will do
anything to keep you from doing that
okay so off your pinky toe no shave your
head no have sex with Jerry no well I
tried to be reasonable I'm gonna go to
the girls bathroom to check the trash
cans for babies but you can dance if you
want whoa where'd you get that the
internet I love cupcakes
Alice hates you Annie has herpes
problem my problem is you smell us Ben
told you to finish the website and if
you don't do it I swear to God I'm gonna
murder you in your sleep I know where
you live 14th Street right I'm gonna get
a melon baller and scoop your eyes out
and your Congressman uncle's gonna have
to buy you a dog to drag your eyeless
face around
do you understand
me do it
okay
why are you dressed as a pilgrim Leslie
said it was a come as you were in the
90s party I assumed it was the 1690s
oh oh girl you look creepy would you
like a drink all this stuff is free no
it's not why'd you pay for a limo
because it's prom you don't show up in a
limo legally they can't let you in does
your mom want to take pictures
she does
Lauren I'm April's mom
you two look adorable just take the
picture already mom
my baby is all grown up have her home by
11. Mom stop embarrassing me say goodbye
to your father
bye Dad good night sir
the air is too fresh it's disgusting I
can't breathe there's a brook somewhere
that won't stop babbling shut up we have
a couple House rolls though yeah sure of
course you can't use the front door you
have to climb in through the back window
no personal phone conversations if you
ever speak to me in Spanish please use
the formal instead and no electricity
after 6 PM a couple more rules if you
ever watch a sad movie you have to wear
mascara so we can see whether or not
you've been crying there's no noise a
lot on Mondays and no TV after breakfast
April I wasn't listening but I strongly
disagree with Anne I want to tell people
what to do and then send them far away
from me it's perfect these are the Black
Eyed Peas
and I finally killed them
it's a Christmas miracle
stay back [ __ ] you ever found a dead
body in the truck
the Torso or head please say head okay
we're getting close
babe you look more beautiful right now
than I've ever seen you
wow just your luck that you're going
into labor on Halloween can I get a warm
towel to get that makeup off no I
know that's the whole point I put
them whatever blows your skirt up okay
you ready to push
wait no babe my birth Max
here comes a contraction are you ready
okay I'm ready let's do this because we
know Spanish right two turntieres into
trabajo porque to eres and Felicia
personal oh good excellent
my mom's Puerto Rican that's why I'm so
Lively and colorful
however the truth is stupid I only tell
the truth when it makes me sound like
I'm lying is this going to be one of
those cool bachelorette parties where
things get out of control and we murder
someone and then we all have to take a
blood Oak to never reveal our secret no
then I might have to leave early I think
I may have found a project I'd actually
enjoy doing
helping these cats and dogs these should
be rewarded for not being people I hate
people
sorry but I am not like you you love
everything the only things I like are
dogs sleeping late and weird birthmarks
you can't make museums about those she's
the worst person I've ever met
I want to travel the world with her I
wanted to make fun of stupid people
while I get drunk my two true passions
you're a perfect guy
um Yao Ming's torso Napoleon's brain and
the Hunchback of Notre Dame's hunchback
do you like my nails
I'm Janet snakehold I'm a very rich
Widow with a terrible secret who are you
I love games that turn people against
each other I hate talking to people
about things this is a nightmare
[Music]
howdy neighbors welcome to human Farm
here's your animal feed please don't
feed the animals
wow this is really really cool
like the statement it's making that you
know we're all in cages in a way yeah
it's actually about death and the city
yeah I see that now
hi Oren
okay so I took extensive notes on ways
to maximize our efficiency because we
can't be just as good as a man we have
to be better yeah you're totally right
let's rock this April I love you but I
don't need your sarcasm right now I'm
serious let's get rolling I want to get
into some garbage
what I love garbage this is Stacy
knoblock's house I went to high school
with her and she was super mean to me
and now I know that she dyes her hair I
knew that wedge wasn't naturally blonde
oh my God
she has to use prescription strength
deodorant
this is the best day of my life this is
your wife how old are you he's 33 and
I'm 47 slash Immortal get out high
school forever